[Music]
[Applause]
the bustier the sparkles only selena
quintanilla could pull off thousands of
fans came out in Hollywood as she
received her star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame we're speaking with her family
as they commemorate her legacy today was
such an emotional special day what does
it mean to you to see her daughter be
honored I'm very proud what do you think
of her legacy being memorialized in such
an amazing way there were so many
thousands of fans today I just want to
thank the fans for loving her so much
yeah we miss her what goes through your
mind when you're sitting there through
that ceremony there are certain things
that make me make me cry one of the
things when I hear a dreaming of you but
today just hearing everybody sweet and
such and just positive empowering words
from very powerful people there was the
moments where my dad and Eddie Eddie
almost were together that that's like
yeah I don't know I didn't want to cry
but I was just I was just it was just
emotional for me I just loved watching
and stuff around great
and I'm very proud of what I interviewed
your dad and Suzette earlier this year
your dad said something that really sat
with me he said in my mind she's still
alive is it the same case for you
yeah there's a music I think yeah
through music videos we want if we want
we're strong enough to deal with her
that day yeah you know and today I was
happy because my mom we all held strong
you don't I'm saying it was it was happy
of it I can't when I came I was in my
room I kind of got a knot in my throat
because I can from my room I can see the
capitol tower and I just was like man
this is just gonna be too overwhelming
you know but it was more for me of a
proud moment it was a proud moment out I
was a proud brother you know as you can
see I always represent have to do that's
something that's something special you
know these custom jackets are everything
yeah I love this jacket you know what it
represents as her colors 7 that's her
birthday it's her birthday when she was
born so she's forever forever and got a
heart on this just this decide right
there next Eileen on the back Selena
tats do you have at this point I have
one well this is the one I really love a
lot but you can't do that here we get a
shot on how painful was that that's very
painful
yeah very family excuse my heart it's
not going you get you keep her in your
heart and in your head in my head she's
in my heart and she's in my mind all the
time what do you miss most about your
sister her lap it's you and make me
laugh no she was so silly
it was kooky to us he really was I'll
miss her always miss her every day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]